people say all the time to me Steven
you're exaggerating these people are not
as predatory as you're saying you're
saying they're always praying on
desperate hopes and dreams what are you
talking about well may I submit for your
consideration daddy dance take care
[Music]
because I wanted to make more money for
my family so that I could support them
of course blurred his face for privacy
reasons they because this story is not
about him it's about Dan Locke who is
selling courses to children who think
they're gonna make money for their
parents now I haven't checked the price
of baseball cards recently I haven't
checked the lemonade stand
at profit margins but you ain't gonna be
rich because you took Dan Locke's course
and the sad thing is is this kid
believes he is he believes he's gonna
make money for his family we find this
thanks to a vision board that this kid
created for the HTC course look at this
I will visit Japan with my mom in March
2021 with my first HTC income he will
become make billions of dollars of
revenue with the company and he will
dedicate himself to a underwater subway
business in 2025 now I do not say this
to mock this kid I'm saying that these
are his expectations when he paid for a
course that costs thousands of dollars
and not only that Dan Locke encourages
it in the comments section yes sure
these are these are reasonable
expectations start young sure why not
why not why not why not why wouldn't we
accept you in our twenty five hundred
dollar program I have to ask you guys
how is this okay
Ann Locke is running all these ads on
YouTube and who's it affecting who is
getting into his course is it people who
can afford it do you need more money Dan
I have to know does Dan need more money
oh right this is this isn't woke Dan
this is the Dan Locker needs to fill up
those two golden money guns ready
expensive to be honest and yes I did I
did go ahead and verify that the kid did
pay for the course at least his parents
did he didn't get the old Dan lock
special free course that might have been
okay but no according to my inside
sources he did not get that so him and
his parents paid all under the pretense
of his parents really probably can't
afford it because he wants to make money
for his parents because apparently I
don't have a lot of money it's extremely
sad not because the kid isn't charming
he certainly is but that we live in a
time where people like Dan lock are
making millions millions of dollars off
the backs of people just like this today
I want to share with you my class two
takeaways but before I showed that night
old man told you about a lesson that I
learned you know how from class one Sifu
told us that the rich did what was hard
that's my girl life is easy poor people
do what is easy never denied his heart
so it was just happen like a few days
ago it was Friday in high school had a
Fall Festival my low self-esteem really
wanted me to go there so he was like hey
let's go to the Fall Festival let's take
a break but my my higher self-esteem was
telling my lower self-esteem that hey no
see who told us that rich people do what
was hard I am NOT going to let you just
pull me back away from my dreams and on
that day my high self-esteem just beaten
my low self-esteem so every time my low
self-esteem just one go to the fall and
kapow and of power until it just shut
itself down and the last one guy learned
was wealth triggers and today I'm going
to share with you my wealth trigger
[Music]
[Music]